we will
also deliver battle tanks to Ukraine
leopard two tanks that is the result of
a very uh close and intense discussions
with our partners with our allies and I
want to say clearly it is important that
we have close cooperation in this matter
and that we continue with this
cooperation
our aim is
uh to deliver two tank battalions
together with our allies there are many
countries that want to join in we will
coordinate it and include these
countries so this will become possible
step by step uh Germany will make
available iPad 2 R6
Hanks
from the Army inventories in Germany and
we will train Ukrainian Crews here we
will make a logistics available
replenishment and we will also allow
partner countries to deliver these tanks
ladies and gentlemen this is the right
principle we are talking about very
effective systems and it is right that
we never
make them available on our own but in
close cooperation with others one final
word there are many citizens in this
country that are worried worried
because of this decision and the
dimensions that the this type of arm
brings about please trust us trust the
government we will continue working at
an international level we have made this
support possible without
the risks increasing into the wrong
direction this is because we have worked
together and we will continue to do so
work with our allies